o show de fora
o generoso quem vai
ae oi meu amor
ae ei ei e oi oi aqui nesse mapa
o tabu
quem é essa taxa ea bula
i fevereiro tá na roça em 1992
eu acompanhei maracatu rural pela
primeira vez em outubro o seu momento
musical chamado neurose e na noite de
natal nesse mesmo ano
eu vim falar o país também o marido de
maracatu rural são tradições a zona da
mata norte e nordeste do brasil
paulo
o gol
a fábrica
ae
beijo
op e silva pereira
i am
hum
o que mais impressiona nessas tradições
é o vigor e alegria ea presença
depois de alguns anos é eu queria saber
o que é que vinha antes do que a gente
vem do que a gente ouve
eu queria saber como onde e o que gerava
esse estado de presença e alegria
o tempo foi passando e eu fui
vivenciando experimentando não só nos
terreiros mas também nos meus trabalhos
de dança de informação e aí eu indiquei
alguns princípios que fundamentam esse
jeito de fazer mas é importante saber
que todo esse fazer é um fazer do corpo
tudo acontece a partir dele e o ponto de
partida é sempre dentro mesmo que uma
motivação vem de fora e se fazer começa
no interior
e nesse interior são impulsos som e
movimento não se diferenciam nesse
interior onde eles vão se diferenciar
quando ultrapassa o limite do que a
gente disse que dentro e fora do corpo
e esse som esse movimento eles surgem
juntos é tão junto que a gente pode até
dizer que é possível ouvir com os olhos
e ver com os ouvidos
o primeiro princípio que identifiquei
desse jeito de fazer
foi quando eu percebi que esses impulsos
quando são revelados quando a gente
percebe ele
eles acontecem de forma contínua mas
essa repetição ao contrário do que pode
parecer
não limita a criatividade então esse é
outro princípio desculpa esse é um dos
primeiros princípios que é som em
movimento que surge dois meses o curso
tem uma relação direta e precisa com a
pulsação percebo que fazer algo com um
pouco de forma regular
numa acusação é muito simples exige
empenho esforço mas é muito simples
perceberam também que rapidamente se
cria um campo muito rico de
possibilidades de encontro à pulsação é
antes de qualquer cultura porque vem
antes do ritmo
o ritmo é uma construção em cima dessa
pulsação e é nessa posição que a gente
começa a percorrer são muito mais
vamos mandar matar naquele verbo
por isso joão baião nos leva até lá é
que passei é preciso uma pensata um
ritmo de jogo nosso mané coquinho e essa
continuidade
traz criatividade com tite negou e faz a
gente escutar a barreira física
é um vai e se tivesse que fazer de outra
maneira
a cintura e depois o recorde chega no
início a gente espera barreira do
presidente até uma barreira chegar em
sexto lugar a água novamente não é a
principal barreira física são passadas e
esta operação vai alegria uma empolgação
ea partir de agora
a energia vai haver energia ganha quem
tem alergia pagar e quanto mais a gente
tiver mais energia vai ganhar e este é o
ministro nesse direito de fazer a
energia se retroalimenta então são esses
quatro princípios básicos desse jeito de
fazer a relação direta e precisa com a
pulsação a continuidade à superação e
retro alimentação de energia
então eu tenho uma intuição
esses princípios a natureza também
utiliza para o seu funcionamento
por que a natureza também cursa a
natureza também se repete de forma
criativa a natureza se supera e se
retroalimenta com sua energia
isso me faz crer que algo que a gente
faça seguindo esses princípios vai nos
conectar com a nossa própria natureza
porque nós também somos natureza
isso me faz crer também que o fazer que
segue esses princípios permite a gente
expressar o que eu chamo da dança do que
somos e como é que a gente pode usar
isso pra não fazer em qualquer contexto
primeiramente é fazer com o corpo
a gente precisa incluir o corpo em tudo
que a gente faz independente do que a
gente faz e fazer a partir de dentro é
preciso incluir dentro porque nesse
dentro que os impulsos surge aí fazer
você tem que fazer a partir desses
impulsos é fazer fazer continuar fazendo
essa continuidade é o que vai trazer
criatividade encontros faz você superar
as barreiras que existem
e com isso você tem satisfação alegria e
você começa a ganhar energia você dá
você recebe e você se potencializa
potencializado você se conecta ainda
mais com o seu corpo se conecta ainda
mais como fazer do outro você fica mais
criativo mas acima de tudo você fica
mais presente você encontra o seu fluxo
então faço um convite
vencemos
eu acho que a dança é a melhor forma da
gente experimentar e praticar o uso
desses princípios
eu também acho que música dança e teatro
são atributos de todo e qualquer ser
humano
então vamos botar uma música discutem
podem escutar com os olhos ver com os
ouvidos percebam a pulsação se conecta
com ela a partir do seu interior e
mantenham-se empenhados nessa conexão e
faça um álbum com corpo e manter ou se
empenhado também nesse fazer aí siga o
fluxo
lembre-se que estão juntos
o acusado se dirigiu para o jb tem que
entrar no famoso aberto na ponta dos pés
à cabeça e acabou barrado
é muito grato
sei marcar o adeus adeus adeus até a
próxima palestra assim querendo do
senhor dono da casa
adeus adeus até o próximo encontro assim
o carinho deles analisou
nosso evento analisou com alegria
andou erro nosso país ea nossa companhia
analisou
nosso é vital na língua com alegria
já no v rom nossa cria a nossa com
aparelho
ae
aqui